you could not live with your own failure
and where did that bring you to new rock
stars creating more theories new rock
stars has this video out Thanos
returning I'm Ron Burgundy
Loki timeline and endgame reset
explained actually no new rock stars has
been doing this thing I think on their
discord through patreon I believe or
they're doing watch lungs for all the
Avengers movies which and that are doing
these breakdowns and I haven't seen any
of those yet as I've been conflicted
about whether or not we should react to
those because that sounds great I've
never actually read any of their movie
breakdowns oh yeah that'd be cool that
would be cool very cool very cool very
cool
with our discussion on top of their 18
minute videos we're looking like a 45
minute video we can even break an hour
and I already have a theory about where
this is because of Loki and the
alternate timelines and the multiverse
I've edited welcome back to new
rockstars I'm Erik Bosse and Thanos
Tuesdays from the MCU appear to be over
but that was also our assumption with
MCU villains like Red Skull Zemo and
Loki series thanks to the Avengers time
Medlen and endgame resurrecting this god
of mischief on his own a branch timeline
from 2012 onward a branch timeline that
oh yeah also includes an ultimate Thanos
perfectly alive and well still on earth
we've been any stones because now that
we're in a Marvel Cinematic multiverse
no one dies and everyone lives on
forever and ever
eggs gonna want an answer for his
failure danos like the MCU is Tony
Soprano you can't get away from that guy
find it choking to death long-suffering
colleges with his daughter but as I have
been step foreign team in this blue
dungeon brie watching Ethan which I
realize that this timeline from 2012
through endgame is very mysterious
if Marvel ever wanted to explore this
alternate Thanos backstory there are a
lot of questions that they would need to
answer to let them great course anno
says new stuff is prequels but it may
open up the MCU in all kinds of
confusing ways but one of the biggest
points of confusion came up with the
ultimate 2014 era Thanos
it's technically the one who died at the
end of the film when present-day nebula
and Rhodey go back to 2014 to get a
Power Stone for more AG we check in
briefly with nebula Gamora from that
point in history their mid battle and
the endgame script actually revealed
their victims as korbinites the
horseface race of beta ray bill
suggesting the planet blow that might be
Gorman anyway 2014 Gamora and Julia 14
nebula have an interesting exchange
father wants us back on the ship
interested he's found an infinity stone
one stone is in six nebulae it's a start
this exchange is setting up the history
we saw guardians of the galaxy set in
2014 when Thanos since Ronan after the
Power Stone but the confusing part is
they specifically say banners finding
the power stone is his first stone that
appears to contradict the events of the
first 2012 vengers movie in which Thanos
sent Loki to earth for the tesseract
which contained the space stone and we
assume that infinity stone was the whole
point of Loki's attack on earth
additionally Loki's scepter at that moon
contained another Infinity stone the
mine stone and the head cannon of many
of us was that day no Slynt Loki one
Infinity stone so that but endgame
declares Thanos his first location of a
stone two years after that in 2014 so
the only way this makes sense is if
Thanos in 2012 did not yet know the
tesseract and Loki's scepter contained
Infinity stones in this case you can
imagine searching the galaxy for all
kinds of powerful mystical weapons but
not sure which of those weapons
contained Infinity stones which them
didn't
so this interpretation of what famous
knew and when he knew it actually helps
explain the confusion around the gap and
banished his own quest timeline and why
people like Thor didn't do more stop him
so remember after guardians Sanders's
stone quest really kicked into gear in
the post-credits scene after age of
Ultron which showed him with an empty
Infinity Gauntlet doesn't appear again
until the post-credits scene of thor
ragnarok Kenshin Thor with his pants
down but in age of Ultron more
experienced a vision showing him the
Infinity stones that movie ended with
him supposedly setting off in search of
them so during that search why didn't he
Santos why didn't you at least know of
what this is doing I'm so surprised to
see thinness and ragnarok and infinity
war our friend AJ Ethel however you see
it brought up this question on this
chord which oh you can actually join
that did score better than the Petri by
the way I mean now there are two points
to make here first in Ragnarok Thor does
hint at some general unrest around the
galaxy but then I decided to go out
there and investigate and what do I find
the nine realms completely in chaos
enemies of Asgard assembling plotting
our demise Thor's implication here is
that Odin or should I stay low-key
masquerading as Odin is shirking his
responsibility to provide order
insecurity across the realms and as a
result all kinds of enemies of Asgard
are making moves' enemies like searcher
like hella in terms of like maybe a big
verbal [ __ ] named Thanos Psychopaths
eco-terrorists amassing an army going
planet by planet culling them by half
but at the end of the day just one bad
actor in a galaxy full of [ __ ]
people like door might know who Santos
is but he would have no reason to know
that Thanos's real plan was to find six
stones and carry out that dark mission
with just a snap now the second point is
that famous with that empty got little
dude we're so glad necessarily take
place right after age of Ultron in 2015
you think about it it couldn't have
because an infinity war we learned that
fan of Scott that gauntlet after sacking
it of Lear the forge that Thor was
shocked to find destroyed in infinity
war years later nineveh Lear is the
primary armory for Asgard if it got
attacked it would be like if a US
military base got hit and some nukes
went missing people would be freaking
out the only way neither blurr could
have been attacked without Thor knowing
is that it happened during the events of
Ragnarok when Thor was distracted
stranded on sir huh interesting so that
would put there as his attack of middle
ear around 2017 and then he would put on
the gauntlets and go after the Power
Stone ons and arm but why does Thanos
wait that long why doesn't he attack
notably earlier after Roman let him down
in guardians of the galaxy in 2014 well
we get this answer in for Ragnarok Odin
Odin is the key here he is the badass
power check of all the nine realms but
his death and Ragnarok is what triggers
all of the chaos afterwards it allows
hella to return
it allows Thanos to finally make his
move many believe that the additional
right-handed gauntlet in vaults wasn't
just a jokey meta easter egg
it was a relic belonging to Odin from
his own past stone quest like imagine
Luton as a younger Asgardian to gather
all six Infinity stones becoming master
of the universe on premiere he was hit
with a pang of guilt for having to
sacrifice the one he loved the most
his daughter hella and in that misery he
decided to give up on the stone quest
and scattered the stones he had gathered
across the galaxy and their forward stop
anyone else from attempting to follow in
his footsteps and that lasted until his
death in 2017 take him out of 2017 was
also shortly after the time stone was
used on earth before Doctor Strange
became a mystic warrior the time stone
remained relatively hidden in the eye of
agamotto rarely if not never used but
then strange changed that all by using
it to defeat Dormammu and events with
cosmic reverberations that could have
put a big target on earth so in 2017 all
the pieces are now in place for Thanos
he knows which of the many powerful
items he sought our Infinity stones
Odin's death opens the door for him to
attack natively r2 get his own gauntlet
and then Thanos has does and arc for the
Power Stone
all the while Thor is too busy getting a
haircut from Stan Lee to know what's
happening now this used to just be a
past history that no longer really
mattered to them to you but now that
stories like Loki are taking place at
ultimate branch history this Panos stone
quest is still playing out in the
background of that branch history it can
still influence and collide with Loki's
journey nanos remains a deadly threat on
a mission with huge cosmic implications
to whatever university is alive in so
don't sleep on a mad Titan because even
if two versions of them are dead there
are infinite more of them to snap your
neck cross granny for The Avengers to do
keeps coming back we already did the one
reality where we win well if this isn't
an example of a video going down a path
that was different than I anticipated I
don't know what
this open up a whole new can of worms
and questions there's some theories here
that I really did like a lot especially
the one with Odin he has his whole
history and lineage explaining why he
truly left hella behind he's set on his
own quest to find the Infinity stones
and his encounter of war mirror put him
in this feeling of despair and so he
decided to spread out the stones across
the galaxies and such I think is a
really cool one this might sound silly
but my thing against the whole idea of
that not just being I met a joke with
hella pushing over the gauntlet that it
was actually Odin's old gauntlet my
argument against that would be that
thing is massive and it seems to only
fit on Thanos azam like that looks like
it's designed specifically for Thanos's
hand so I would still take it as just a
joke unless Odin has some ability to
make his hand grow massive giant arm
fist the size of that yeah honestly
that's like one argument against that
theory is that doesn't look like it
would fit him and if Tony Stark is able
to develop some type of technology that
would be able to fit onto his hand or
Hulk's hand I bet that they would be
able to figure out how to make one for
Odin specifically for his account let's
are made in their own intergalactic
smelting plant yeah yeah it seemed like
that this Hulk theory that was being
posed here of Thanos returning it seemed
like we were getting two theories one
theory was we could just explore the
timeline gap like really get a chance to
see what Thanos was doing exploring some
of the wars that were taking place and
such maybe some of the other things he
searched for the words Infinity stones
yeah kind of getting like sideline plots
or whatever maybe not in a movie but in
the shows especially with dimension
traveling universe traveling with one
division and more time traveling with
Loki so then you could really get some
fun cameos or storylines to explore with
Thanos I guess I I don't know if we'd be
shoehorned or something personal for
Loki specifically my question comes down
to that
I'm travelling and the timeline stuff
that we saw happen in endgame from my
understanding and I know the time travel
thing has been a little bit difficult
for people to truly wrap their heads
around but the most part I got it like I
didn't ever had a difficult time hopping
onto it but then when I'm thinking about
this storyline with this slow key that
we're going to be exploring in the
series that's where I start getting a
little bit confused that Loki went to
earth upon Thanos orders was that the
Thanos that died at the end of endgame
though right isn't that what it was
implying that it was that same Thanos so
with the hook you have anything to worry
about would there be a reason for fan
o's to go after Loki that's a good
question yeah I guess in that
arrangement it wouldn't be is the Loki
show gonna be taking place around the
Loki who escapes during the time-travel
you know scenario in the base yeah be in
the building yeah it wouldn't make sense
okay see that's where the time gaps
start coming into play because Gardens
Agassi was 2014 right yeah and that's a
2014 Thanos who died at the end of
endgame so the 2012 vanos the one word
that which is 2012 Loki which is the
Loki we're focusing on yes is that 2012
tan oh it's gonna be going after load
yeah that's actually a really good
question to ask and I figure it could
certainly happen and I feel like that
would definitely create an event that
people need to go to Disney Plus to
check out yeah it would be smart yeah I
guess although very expensive if Thanos
is still in the search for the stones
but then again that 2014 Thanos does go
to our timeline our earth because we
have acquired all the stone then he has
a line about you took care of all the
hard work for me yeah yeah yeah that's
the trouble with these theories mana
Twitter stuff and I'm over here going
well if Odin made this big vibe for the
stones a while ago with Thanos have
heard about that why why wouldn't you
just come and attack Odin yeah even if
Odin holds the realms together I don't
think Santos is just gonna be like I
can't beat this guy I mean I like the
mysticism of that I do but yeah I kind
of figure like Thanos wouldn't care I
think that you can still get that us to
return in some fashion whether it be the
way how Ronan
earns and Captain Marvel I feel like
though if you have a fan us returning
that they're gonna want to make it
something more meaningful and impactful
then Ronin have what they do with him
and yeah marble you know they're gonna
want to make him a probably a prevailing
character but I don't think it would
happen for a while especially because it
was all that hype we got over stano's
and then Dennis is defeated yay we won I
feel like it'd be a while longer even
though everything's been pushed because
of the virus it's let's wrap your head
around but the the idea of Thanos
returning is a very plausible idea
because you could just be a fan of a
different timeline or something like
that my theory is they're gonna bring
him back for like a an El Camino style
one scene where it's just him talking to
live you know and influencing him to go
get the stone yeah what do you think
about this theory do you want to see
Thanos return even though it's a
different Thanos timeline leave your
thoughts down below these timelines have
everything you can bring back Iron Man
now technically speaking start a whole
new Iron Man franchise what if this
thing was a little different subscribe
to the reel rejects click that
notification bell to get notified never
got a new video up and also subscribe me
new rockstars last night at least and
this so liver I just want to take time
out to you sincere shout out I want to
say thank you so much for being you
the way you chime in on our live streams
the way you interact with us at patreon
and then we talked on social media from
time to time you've been nothing but an
incredibly sweet genuine loving human
being to both John and I and I am
forever grateful to have you in our
lives and I hope one day we can meet in
person and that way John can pump you up
at the gas station today this is your
gonna do it I'm sorry no breach in our
harness we're gonna give a little you
know the gas light that comes on in your
car that's what we're all gonna get just
to commemorate this but also seriously -
I mean like the work that you do is
really important as well especially now
and I hope that you're staying safe and
thank you for you know helping the world
salute you know thank goodness up be
safe take care of your family we will
see you one day soon premium unleaded